some people tend to be very good at  using metrics based on themselves and  they're they kind of ignore  the world around them and they kind of  develop narcissistic qualities they just  see  everything in terms of their own desires  and their own metrics and then there are  other people who  only see things in terms of the metrics  of the people around them they  they're very bad at developing metrics  of success for themselves  my take has always been that a healthy  individual is able to  to do and hold on to both simultaneously  and that's a struggle for most people i  think most people are coming from one of  those two  directions to get to that healthy place